[Musique]
à vous quatre je vous souhaite la
bienvenue dans le foyer de la chambre
des communes devant vous vous avez le
cabinet du gouvernement trudeau avant
l'élection il ya 157 députés libéraux
moi je veux lancer la discussion avec
des ténors du gouvernement trudeau du
dernier mandat à savoir qu'est ce qui
arrive avec ces gens adorent va
commencer comme ça monsieur morneau
ministre des finances est ce qu'il reste
en place qui veut se lancer que oui
pourquoi
d'une part parce que le ministre des
finances et la stabilité économique
c'était le mot d'ordre du gouvernement
trudeau alors je pense pas moi qui
veulent repartir à zéro là dessus je
vous dirais que quand c'est un
gouvernement minoritaire vous avez
besoin de gens d'expérience on s'entend
là-dessus qu'on est encore au goût de la
dame non alors ce serait qu' à la
finance au pressing madrilène parce que
elle a joué un rôle exceptionnel dans le
dernier cabinet et je pense qu'elle peut
pas s'en aller aux institutions
démocratiques ou à autre chose il faut
caler un cabinet qu'à l'époque il est
quelque chose d'important succès ou moi
je le vois plutôt gérer les provinces ou
si les premiers mais il faut pas oublier
la personne en libérateurs saskatchewan
des problèmes avec l'ouest et problème
aussi avec le québec des problèmes et
des premiers ministres conservateurs et
mme adam freeland pour jouer ce rôle d'
être l'interlocutrice parlant aux
différents
premier ministre conservateur on est
tous d'accord qui de mieux que la chef
de la diplomatie canadienne
je pense qu'il est bien parti on a des
majorités pour ça alors on n'est pas que
madame plus il est non a dit donc des
affaires intergouvernementales
on va ajouter ceci pourrait avoir
quelque chose de supplémentaire aussi
parce que res premièrement on va ajouter
vice premier ministre est ce que tout le
monde est d'accord avec ça moi j'en
verrai garneau aux affaires mondiales
parce qu'il ya le panache pour le faire
vous souhaite à vous et angers là-dessus
quoi faire alors monsieur garneau avait
un mondial si comme ça pour monsieur
garneau une autre possibilité aussi de
diffuser l'environnement en deux alors
du climat austère du climat il ya
ministère de l'environnement parce que
ça va faire des gros dos si la dernière
affaire dont a besoin cette vidéo c'est
de les chiens ouais c'est vrai et avant
deux à l'environnement alors ça ça
marche pas j'ai joué le chaud et le
froid
moi je pense que madame mécanos ne
restera pas l'environnement ces
dernières semaines ont été difficiles à
l'environnement est peut-être trop
polarisé vis-à-vis certains certains
groupes et on sait que les négociations
avec l'ouest seront pas faciles mais
ceci est un monsieur guilbeault à mon
point de vue ne touche repos docile
environnementale interne comme dit
lawrence dans les cabinets les groupes
de travail alain terne que personne le
voile pour le satisfaire
mais je le vois soit aux transports ou
aux infrastructures est-ce qu'on est
d'accord là dessus monsieur guilbeault
transport est ce que ce sont quelque
chose dans mon nom je pense que monsieur
gardons devrait sauter il ya entrepris
des négociations importantes et doit les
terminer à l'innovation science commerce
interne moi je trouve cette touche
l'avenir de l'économie et monsieur
guilbeault sentirez à l'aise avec ses
préoccupations environnementales
cela étant dit madame du kenya je pense
que s'il l'a déplacé ça serait cédée à
certains groupes et ça serait très mal
vu alors est-ce qu'on s'entend pour dire
qu'on laisse madame mais quesnel la non
reste jamais très la justice mali
d'avocate ensemble
oubliée j'ai commencé la vallée c'est
pas facile justement pour ça que je la
vois dans la tare you justice juste ça
parle fort de la justice pour madame
mais kenneth si vous voulez on écoute et
jose atteindre on atteint le hockey
elles ne sont par ailleurs son baroud ou
[Musique]
par lots de l'ouest parce qu'ils se
référer à l'ouest
monsieur trudeau a le la difficulté
parce qu'il n'ya pas de siège entre
winnipeg et vancouver
c'est pour ça que je pensais que google
allait jouer un rôle à l'intérieur de
son cabinet j'aime l'idée de dollars nz
de nommé conseiller spécial au bureau du
premier ministre abdou day qui
finalement c'est pas facile à remplacer
brad écosse était comme un jeu solide
j'en ai c'est qu'en valeur et du premier
ministre alors moi je ne nommerai pas de
génie de sénateurs dix de gens qui sont
venus qui viennent de l'extérieur
surtout si vous mettez un cabinet pas je
pense que ça va faire énormément de
grogne on a vous avez votés l'ouest il
nous manque ressources naturelles et mme
colle naturelle
[Musique]
programme dans lequel je la mettais
jeunesse et aux sports et communautés
non se passer à 2,5 en valeur d'après
moi oui tiens champions de l'olympique
de kayak je crois donc vous pensez que
ça va venir avec une récompense qui s'y
est un gros con té qui est allé chercher
[Musique]
marie-france lalonde va être un
excellent musicien évoquera copponi
pourquoi madame lalonde se passe en
second lieu de ministres hollande à la
francophonie d'un gouvernement de wind
en fait ma bilan avec soi et l'autre
élément c'est qu'elle va pouvoir à être
une porte parole ou des francophones
voilà ontario et de se tenir debout par
rapport à ça est ce qu'il ya des
certitudes c'est à dire des gens soient
que l'on reconduit dans leurs fonctions
ou qu'on est assez sûr qu'il soit à
table du cabinet est ce que quelqu'un
qui veut cela mélanie c'est sûr que le
vainqueur mélanie joly c'est certain
qu'avec là est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec développement des familles oui
exactement famille enfin et
développement social un bon ministère
pour mélanie joly
[Musique]
on a peut-être besoin jeu pour la
sédition comme ça d'un lieutenant
québécois alors là dessus est-ce qu'il
ya je vous attends d'opposition
là-dessus peut-être commence par
monsieur de cette campagne pour mon
soutien à ce que fabregas à l'extérieur
de montréal
c'est quelqu'un qui a été habile des
relations un peu partout à raison des
infrastructures
je pense qu'on est tous d'accord mais ce
que ça exclut le fait qu'il ya un mini
stage mais voilà on la verrait où les
infrastructures parce qu'il faut que
celui donne la capacité de pouvoir
négocier tout à fait infrastructures
your
une sacoche boys band à l'immigration
je vais me ranger à l'hydrogène un jeune
député
cela veut dire que je sois réponse à mon
pire ennemi du québec parce que ça va
être une filière pas facile avec les
collègues et je suis pas sûr de cendres
parce que l' inverse imaginer que
quelqu'un d'ailleurs du québec daniel et
sa ca.fr facile alors on y va avec les
migrations bon monsieur david est ce
qu'on est d'accord avec ce que l'on voit
lâché que c'est pas nécessairement et on
peut pas s'entendre sur tout je pense
que vous pouvez vous applaudir merci
beaucoup
bravo à nous mais c'est pas compris ce
qu'est ce qui doit garder en tête
monsieur trudeau en quelques mots ou
pour les prochaines semaines mais
trudeau doit garder en tête l'unité du
pays doit regarder les finances doit
regarder la relation avec les états unis
et l'environnement ça va être
définitivement son cheval de bataille
ça sera pas facile et je pense qu'il
faut que mettre des gens solides bleu tu
es je dirais moi le mot clé pour son
cabinet puis son caucus au complet ça va
être discipline je m'envoie sa première
conférence de presse peut-être élections
et après un engagement et je vais
réfléchir donc au choix entre est fléché
prix pareil et on a oublié de nommer
monsieur singh d'un cabinet je remercie
beaucoup d'avoir participé à notre défi
aujourd'hui maintenant on va aller voir
le résultat final
[Musique]